hello everyone and welcome to the last
game will be showing from the tiebreaks
of the quarterfinals of the feeder World
Cup 2019 and definitely the most
interesting game
it's youngji vs. Nikita which ago and
this is the Armageddon game so two of
the classical games they played have
been wronged and two rapid games have
been drawn then youngy
won the second rapid game the one with
the shorter time formats then we tube of
equalized by winning his game and then
they went into the blade section both of
the Blitz game have been drawn and now
we have the Armageddon youngji has five
minutes with the white pieces whereas
fatigue of has four minutes with the
black pieces but he you know he's
satisfied with a draw so if this game is
drawn with you go goes into the
semi-finals to face Dingley run without
further ado let's just check it out and
this is just well you'll see what I mean
by it we don't have a photo there this
again compliments of the official
photographer kieran mercury of there you
have it
still we have yet to see a photo where
there's actual eye contact between the
players but there's a I'm sure there's a
good reason to this maybe if someone
studies you know human behavior maybe
you can shed some light onto this but if
not you know we can just enjoy the photo
so there we have it without further ado
let's check out the game youngji opens
with efore with east six the French
defense and now f4 already very
interesting from the start the board on
a variation with d5 by black and now II
five advancing the point with c5 as you
always want to play c5 mostly in the
French defense and Knight to f3
we have Knight to c6 and the now c3 may
be preparing d4 at some point with
Knight to h6 not preparing to bring this
Knight over to f5 white ghost Knight a3
the night is coming to see tube the
further prepare the d4 thrust and the
now Knight to f5
with nice to see to and here this
position has been reached many times for
example Magnus cross and had it with the
white pieces both against Greece shook
in the Norway blitz championship he won
that game and also against Richard
report in the st. Louis blitz
championship course and also won
game the difference is the Grisha played
a Bishop d7 whereas the reporter went
for the knight exchange with the knight
to h4 but here we have d4 by with Google
it's not a new move it's it's just a
different line Bishop to d3 going after
the knight on f5 and now Knight to h4
now not allowing this capture and here
there is one game where castles was
played which which makes sense your g2
Pony is under attack you don't want to
just give it up or do you because here
instead of castles the yongi played
Bishop to e4 and it's really it really
doesn't make sense it's it's as if this
line this beautiful line of giving up
all these pawns it specifically made how
hard to play an Armageddon game where
you absolutely must win I haven't
checked the interview after the game
whether this is a this is a blunder or
of two points on the King set or is this
just you know giving up points for for
some super activity but it's just
amazing
so the g2 pawn is free for grabs and of
course a video captures that we have
Knight captures and g2 with check King
to f2 and the mountain Knight captures
on f4 so grabbing both of the pawns now
there are lines of the King's gambit for
example where you first can be the F
pawn then you gambit the Jeep on he
captures then you even allow G captures
on h2 but what we'll always have we'll
always have a lot of development and a
lot of place before those sacrifice
pawns but here it's it's really just
weird but okay
d3 white continues development like
nothing happened the night is under
attack and the V to go brings it back
with Knight to g6 and here C captures on
d4 we have C captures on d4 and now
Bishop to g5 continuing development life
nothing happened attacking the black
Queen with Bishop to e7 and now even
trading material being down material
Bishop captures on e7 with King Queen
captures on e7 and now Knight captures
on d4 a regaining some material ix
capture Sonny five black grabs upon with
Knight captures Knight captures and now
Queen to h5 repair preventing castles as
if castles then Queen to h7 will be
checkmate so Knight to d7
preparing night to have sex to kick away
the queen and also guarded the h7 bond
with rook H to g1 now preparing to
capture on G on g7 and here best for
black is g6 it really just gets rid of
any threats along this diagonal gets rid
of the Queen if Queen f6 6 then you get
to Queen to f6 check and then you
continue development with E 5 denied
develops you can bring the bishop into
the game and so on but here Knight to f6
right away by vehicle attacking the
Queen and guarding his h7 pawn we have
Queen to e5 now again the g7 point is
under attack and now with Knight
captures on e4 width check D captures on
e4 and now f6 first kicking away the
Queen and Queen to h5 check inviting
black to further weaken his King side or
to offer a queen trade of course
Whitaker is very satisfied with a queen
trade as he's up material so he offers a
queen trade but of course you only the
clients we have Queen to c5 now again
preventing the castles and here Queen to
e7 a V to gov again offers a queen trade
but this is a this is a bad offer Oh
Queen trade because it allows capture
and rook captures on g7 better offer of
a Queen trade was Queen to f8 while
still keeping an eye on the g7 point
here if the Queen's are traded then the
King also defends the g7 point and if
Queen c7 then you go Queen B for also
threatening the beat upon threatening
the night here with check the Queen can
infiltrate with Queen to d2 if needed
but ok we do go play the Queen to e7 he
we have to remember it's a blitz game
Queen captures on e7 with check King
captures and then our rook captures on
g7
with King to f8 and now rook a to g1 and
black is still up upon but White's
doubled the rooks along the G file and
the active night more than compensate as
black still has all of these undeveloped
pieces how are you gonna get the rook
center game and how are you getting the
bishop inter game with if I first frame
this diagonal for the bishop but now
Knight the b5
preparing Knight the c7 followed by
the d5 and then the knight wants to come
to f6 which will completely immobilize
the black King and here the what you
want to play is the rook to b8 you don't
bother yourself with with the a7 point
if white captures it then you activate
your rook it's not a problem
and you don't allow Knight c7 to come
with tempo so basically what you're
doing here is you're waiting for the
night to move so you can play b5 develop
your rook this way and then you're gonna
play h5 and hopefully develop your other
look this way but in the game a six was
played and this allows white to move the
knight with tempo with nice the c7
attacking the rook rook to b8 and now
Knight to d5 going after f6 with f5 not
allowing Knight to the capture on f6 and
now Knight to f6 and here you can see
that the black King can no longer move
anywhere we have F captures on e4 but
now comes roof to c7 with the deadly
threat the threat now as the King can
move can't move anywhere is just rook to
g7 followed by rook to f7 checkmate
so black starts developing we have
Bishop to f5 preparing to meet rook g7
with bishop g6 to keep an eye on the f7
square we have rook g2 g7 and now Bishop
back to g6 now preventing the rook f7
mate and do not look G to d7 again just
the black black doesn't really have
anything to do white now wants to push
h4 h5 push away the bishop and then of
course just win the game so b5 black is
hoping to somehow develop develop the
rook but for the moment it's impossible
as you would just get made it it's it's
not not an option with h4 white
continues with his plan of h5 and black
prevented with h5 but now that you've
played h5 your bishop is no longer
defended so just look the g7 and what do
you do with the bishop again if you move
it then the rook f7 is checkmate if you
don't know what you're gonna lose it so
what can you do well Bishop t8 comes to
mind but it's not a good idea if Bishop
Tate if Bishop da then white is
completely winning even felt free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for white as
you might be able to use it in some of
your own games while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent mater into and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's
actually Ruby g8 check sort of a mini
smothered mate roof captures and
mountain i2h size checkmate the rope
covers the entire seventh rank and the
black stone pieces prevented the black
King from going anywhere quite quite a
nice idea so and you should know it for
example if you get this position in a
blitz game so you don't have to waste
time looking for it but okay we have
looked the see it now hoping for this
trade rook captures and keen captures
where black would definitely be okay but
here white just trades down into a
favorable endgame into a much more
favorable endgame with rocky g8 check so
the King cannot capture the rook has to
capture and only now does white capture
and see it we're up capture Sun c8 with
check King f7 and the night and now
picks up the rook and here white is up a
full rook King to e7 and now King to e3
just black and easily resigned here but
you came so far in the World Cup you
will play a few more moves King ee7
attacking the rook rook e8 we have
Bishop to f5 and now rook captures on a6
and it was in this position that Nicky
DeVito resigned the game and after an
intense battle of this is like they
played like two classical's for rapid to
blitz as I said and this is 9 so it took
nine games for yongi to eliminate a
negative it to go but in the end he was
he was able to do it so yeah really just
amazing stuff and I've never seen this I
don't know if it was a blunder or it was
elaborate design for an Armageddon game
but whatever it is I really enjoyed it
like giving up those two points was
really amazing so yeah that's that's it
we took a result and yongi advances to
face ding Liron in the semi-finals of
defeated World Cup 2019 whereas MVL will
face a team order job of and I believe
MVL said during an interview that so far
all of he all of the games he played
against our job of ended in a draw but
it's a different story in
case of the England versus yongi in
their matchup Bingley Rijn won six games
young g10 and 15 games were drawn so
Dean definitely a huge favorite too when
it comes to classical chess but we'll
see what happens here it seems like the
ding is a huge favor it doesn't
regardless of who is on the other side
of the board but you know it's just
anything can happen
sure that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it at least you know half as how
much I enjoyed it as I really enjoyed it
I would like to thank some welcome Uli
pro Thomas Mahajan Carson Kent
I got matters dog and Gil trade so for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video series
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the semifinals of the feeder
World Cup checking up in our suggestions
and well and so on so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day